the Queen on v6 is putting pressure on
before and also putting pressure on b2
so you're putting a lot of pressure on
d4 and b2 here okay and that is the idea
in the in a French at advance you want
to try to put as much pressure as
possible okay okay welcome everyone to
the Sunday 2:00 p.m. class this is more
advanced class I'm going to talk about
some openings here and the opening is I
will let you guess the move the name of
this opening is French defense ok this
is a very good defense a very
interesting defense now white plays d4
d5 now do you know what are the moves
were the far four main moves here for
white to play where are the four main
modes that white can play against the
French defense there are four different
lines and all these moves have a name so
first one yes
you mean take yeah you can take do you
know the name for this line this has a
name this has a name that was excellent
who has the name here for me you
exchange variation because you exchange
yeah you take it
that's called everybody what is this
variation called exchange everybody got
it
exchange variation next one we're gonna
learn now ePHI what is this one instead
of exchange
he pushed there what is the name for
this line here close
another name another name you gotta give
me you advance because what do you do it
upon you advance it right and that is
called advanced variation everybody got
it advance yeah
push advance if you take it's called
exchange advance exchange remember that
advance exchange that's what you got to
remember okay now yes assuming Knight to
c3 he plays correct now what is the name
of this variation question is I would
say at the moment at a very high level
where the professionals play you know
the top grandmasters play this is the
most challenging move against the French
defense now let's see who can tell me
the name it's very popular yes
well that's the move Knight c3 classical
guys the classical variation you play
friendship classical you are the
classical right I know you don't know
but they can play against you so we got
that what is this phone give me the name
this one and now classical okay and the
last one so this is I'm introducing to
you what would happen when you play the
French okay what are the likely options
they will play against your French and
now 90 Q what is the idea
word is the idea guys after 92 war is
this cold here huh please please sit
here sheep so you can see this is named
after a very strong chess players very
strong chess player with a difficult
last name you use no no it's named after
a strong player what do you know you
know what do you know you know this guy
he's played like 200 years ago yeah
what's his name
parish doctor doctor Zeek bear parish
okay
ZigBee parish that's the name of death
so that's why they call this line is
harsh variation Tara got it
garage and this is which world champion
from Russia played this move for a long
time with lots of success which water
champion from Russia he was the master
no from Russia was not Russia
yeah now what did he play here
world's champion from Russia yes close
very close
who did Garry Kasparov win to become a
world champion you remember that name
who did he defeat it to become the world
champion for the first time which
players with a very similar last name
yes
Anatoly Karpov yes
all right so Anatoly Karpov is the
Mastiff master of this opening okay so
Karpov all right
and so these are the four main lines
okay there are some other side lines
they can play as well here such as 22
and this is a strange-looking move but
it has a very specific idea the idea is
if you play d5 he takes and you can take
back because of the pin okay so Queen e2
is another idea so Knight f3 is another
idea okay there is also some d3 but
let's focus now on the main lines so
specifically the exchange line because
what you guys go to tournaments you're
gonna see a lot of exchange variations
you're gonna see a lot of advanced
variations okay so you take
Knight c3 9ft pardon 96
Bishop c5 so this line is the called the
copycat line okay
the copycat line so it goes Bishop d3
now what do you do copy so how do we
copy perfect now he castles New Castle
alright Bishop g5 we're gonna continue
the same setup okay what is the next
next setup copycat continues right
Bishop g4 92 symmetrically a hundred
percent symmetrical position C 3 D plays
Queen c2
Brooksie you want perfect now now in
this position it's important to know
whoever plays the H upon move first it's
gonna be slightly worse it's actually
considered a slight mistake slight
inaccuracy - because we you know people
like to just attack the bishop thinking
it's not an identity but it's actually a
problem because now you drop the bishop
here and now your idea is to go Bishop
g6 to trade the bishops but he cannot do
the same thing because if he does this
you can take here twice so he cannot do
the same thing okay now he takes
now he goes here
there's 56 trade the bishops he takes
you take rocky the black is very
comfortable here because this dark
square bishop cannot go backwards you
know so he's kind of stuck so he goes
here and now you need to maneuver the
night you need to maneuver the night
here yes
who has a question okay because if you
move the bishop back that's a play this
you go here right you don't have a pawn
here any longer and I can just take take
and I win a pawn okay you lose a pawn
and position of your King is also weak
here so that's why you don't want to do
that okay so here 93 you will just go
tonight f8 with idea 96 and very
comfortable yes
kobish page - that's a possibility but
what are you gonna accomplish with it
yeah okay
so let's review it until here I want to
see if you guys can get here seventeen
moves that's a lot of moves okay but
it's a pretty easy line it's symmetrical
so let's see if you can do this alright
let's see go ahead
you can just say the first note you see
you say the most of a block okay so we
have which opening now all right he
takes once he takes we know that he's
playing with line exchange variation now
now what they do Knight f3
[Music]
now Bishop d3 castles Bishop g5 perfect
very nice very solid
and now I add my head yeah so remember
as a French player you should you know
if you decide to play this opening you
have to remember that in French defense
the problem is your life screw bishop so
when you have a chance you want to trade
the light square bishop okay so that's
why you play the move Bishop g6 here's
trading the lights squared bishop okay
so he takes you doing 90 feet because
you want to play 96 and just go back a
little bit but then you're gonna
reactivate reactivate the position of
the night okay Nyjah for each the stake
yeah and now you are the very
comfortable okay so that is a line of
your French defense okay
now let's take a look at the line in
advance so when he plays he fired the
point of this move is to advance the
pawn and try to gain space but the
problem with the movies he is moving the
pawn again so that gives you a chance to
try to attack his center and now how
you're going to attack that center
ticker but what do you do first before
you play 96 Bishop before he has c3 yes
c5 first right to attack the center now
you attacking that Center and forcing
the move c3
he plays c3 96
now what do we play here so he plays
Knight f3 and now you want to activate
your queen you want to activate your
queen and put pressure again the target
is the d4 pawn so you want to activate
your queen no Queen goes to B 6 because
Queen on B 6 is doing a great job the
Queen on B 6 is putting pressure on
before and also putting pressure on b2
so you're putting a lot of pressure on
d4 and b2 here okay and that is the idea
in the in a French at advanced you want
to try to put as much pressure as
possible okay very good down he plays
Bishop d3 okay and this book is actually
a trap so if you try to take the pawn
here thinking take take it looks like he
only has one defender right it looks
like it's just the one defender listen
it feels like yeah but there is a
problem in the position
yeah if you take now what would happen
yeah can you take and now what do you do
the Quinn discovery check and wins the
Queen okay you don't want to take on
before here because you want to try to
develop the piece first okay you want to
develop the piece and block the check so
which piece you want to develop and
block the check which piece you're going
to develop and slock the trick
be sure to d7 your man yes perfect now
you want to take so if he tries to
defend now go Bishop here now this
bishop is a target how can you attack
this bishop now you want to play very
active okay now you want to play very
active here what move can you play here
yes correct
attacking the bishop now I think Castle
you just take the bishop you play rook
c8 you're very comfortable
so he goes Bishop b3
and now what move can you play here to
stop him from canceling because he is
trying to counsel now he is trying to
make sure his King is safe here but you
can make a move here and prevent him
from castling
yes
close very close
what's the better version of that movie
yeah Queen on b5 is gonna be kind of a
target so you don't want that yes close
yes
yes yes Queen a six now stopping the
opponent from coming here and look at
that nice control okay nice nice control
you have and now he cannot castle
because your queen is covering that
square so if he goes here now why is
this for losing losing yes yes you want
to try to check here trying to check
here yeah yes no not you him
check if he goes here look at you just
take this look at that look at that so
if he goes here now what do you do are
you can take on Peter - if he goes
king f1 sorry but then it was Queenie -
guys it's very you take a piece yeah
it's very you take a piece then do that
ok
well you could play night at four but I
mean if he goes away no I interstate
okay if you play stinky too you can just
go night be to this you take one of two
you win if it goes here you just take
here you win the Quinn and if it goes to
f1 take how do you win a Quinn because
it's a check it's a check King has to
move and you take on do you want yeah
can't customer when we take on deewana
this idea it's called discovery check
okay you're moving the night and you're
doing a discovery check okay
let's review this okay and then we're
gonna do some practice games okay go
[Music]
so once he plays this which line we have
French advance and when French advance
happens we try to attack the center
[Applause]
[Music]
now this is a trap again don't fall for
the trap yet what do you do first
hey take again the trap is the following
if you take he takes you take discovery
check picking up the Queen okay
discovery check that picks up the Queen
so he has to and if he cancels now you
can just take the pawn on d4 okay so he
plays Bishop let's say c2 trying to
defend Castle is probably his main line
and now yes perfect Bishop b3 if he
castle you just take again it's part of
his best move but you're just
comfortable attack night here night here
you should hear you're just very
comfortable here
it should be three
Knight c3 now what do we do okay now if
he goes to d2 will just take on f2
winning the Queen
if he goes to e2 we just take on c1
check then we can take the bishop it's a
it's a double check yeah and then you
take the bishop and actually sorry King
f1 we play Knight c1 check and then win
the bishop if you place kingi 291 is
still waiting but even better move here
is naívi to check and that King has to
work and then you're taking the Queen
you're winning his most valuable piece
okay okay so this was the introduction
for you to the advance advance exchange
and advance validation of the frame is
it in a future class that we're gonna
try to play now we're gonna now we're
gonna do now we're gonna play some games
in the future classes I will cover the
other two lines okay the classical and
the Tarrasch the classical with Knight
c3 and the tirage variation okay all
right
very good good job guys on the two lines
advance erection
[Music]